competition is business stiff in the
first deck let's see how the goals in
the next round
are you ready what is a loosey now I
should know this
smoke bang that's you it's absolutely
correct a single cigarette a little
cigarette that is correct
a cigarette that is correct
what is a loosey is that a way of saying
oral sex no but we should start saying
this what evolution one cigarette bought
at the store from the a rat that is
correct
a cigarettes bought at the store one
loose cigarette from an array what is a
chickenhead that's a woman who puts her
mouth on the member sometimes called a
crack whore that is acceptable a
fallacious woman there we go mark things
are looking up see somebody on TVs say
chicken head you're such a chicken head
somebody would show this is what I'd
like to see it
somebody's stupid no a chicken head is a
hoochie whore or a fallacious woman
apparently it can be used for different
things it's mostly used to describe a
hoe or an ugly woman a woman that likes
to suck penis penis to give a loosey
that's right you can find out anywhere
and a hood on a block suburb one of
those that you just bring home and well
that is correct that is correct
that's what they're for that's how
they're used finish this good time lyric
temporary layoffs good times easy credit
ripoffs good times
scratching and surviving good times
blank good times I know that one
character on good times is JJ Walker
it's very good
and get mistaken for Moet in shopping
malls another actress on good times as
lenny Kravitz's mother oh I'm sorry that
was the Jefferson
we do we got
yeah when Willie's had a drinking
problem scratching and surviving good
times like good times
mm-hmm and I've always wondered this
myself and it sounds like but it's it's
and is it say it one more time say what
you just said one more time manage order
and I always thought as a kid does that
mean that someone is hung in a jury but
I I didn't I you know I have to say you
can tell I know the the the actual song
but those are ones I ever could decipher
what it was it was Brian's Heather just
pointed out in fact that is very true
this is the most disputed lyric in all
of the good times lyrics yes I am
including to give him the point that
look at my judges he gets the point all
right what is the lyric the correct
lyric hanging in a chili I had to look
it up on the internet myself what is
hanging
and now for the final question are you
ready I'm ready
how can black people rise up and
overcome how can they rise up and
overcome
can they that is correct reparations
that is acceptable this is a rap lyric
no this I'm sorry this is a general
question all right that's a there's a
complex answer there that is correct
stay alive that is correct that is
correct well stop cutting each other's
throat that also is correct how can
black people rise up and overcome get
out and vote
[Applause]
Oh folks our judges tallied up the
scores and we have a winner
Rob the DJ Rob come on out excellent job
Rob congratulations here's the grand
prize of course it contains a lifetime
supply of Murray's hair cream that's
right and one pan is a lifetime supply
trust me to bootleg DVDs and of course
what would a grand prize be without a
pack of menthol cigarettes